Well, come everybody to another Zoom call. If you're new
You've entered
muted if you want to speak in a question you can unmute yourself or
If you want to just chat in the question most people just put it in the chat
But we have a bunch of questions here that
People submitted the member site and remember some of which questions on the member site will get to those first to then we'll get to the questions on the chat
Remember any
announcements on the member site last week we didn't have a Zoom call
And we've had issues with our
Video site getting hacked so that's all fixed so everything should be up and running now
But let's jump right into the questions
First question I am having all sorts of problems with my true life machine since I didn't update
I have heard a ton of complaints online about true life since the company was sold. Is there anything I can do?
Well, yeah, if you have a trouble getting to your programs that I created for you
Then I would suggest that you let us fix it
As far as people having troubles with true life
I would agree that
There is a lot of scuttle but online now I belong to a Facebook group true right Facebook group and some other right Facebook groups a lot of complaints online
And we've been getting a lot of calls of
People having issues with their true right machine
I would agree and it's very
Unfortunate that the new owners are not supporting their machines. They don't do any support on anything. That's an F117
So
That is we again will do everything we can to fix anything that you're having issues with usually if it's a programming issue
Let's say you do an update
Again reminder do not do any updates on your frequencies on your true right
We used to have people update their true right frequencies on a very regular basis some people did it every month some people did it every three months
The new orders
Are not
Doing any new programs so
There's no absolutely zero need to run an update
So do not run any updates on your true right program and
So if but if you can't get to your programs you have a trouble getting your problems just give us a call let us do things and work on it
We'll be glad to help you with that. So I don't I don't remember
You were somebody that called us about getting to your program programs or not, but
If it's just having some issues with some quirks of the machine we could maybe help you to so let us know
Okay, next question
I purchased my right back in
2021 but had to set it in for repair in February I
Paid for a hyper drive repair
Which I'm not sure
Means they repaired it or replaced it does this mean I now have the new crappy board you were talking about in the last Zoom call
I don't know remember who asked this question. I don't remember if
If you have an F1 17 or an F1 22
I
Don't know the only way I would know if you have the good board or the bad board is to open it up and look at it
but
I don't know how I'd be able to tell you how to do that
So I apologize, but I don't know the answer to that
For those that made up
No, when I'm talking about the
older true rights
The older F1 22's and the older F1's and all the F1 17's
Have the Attilia Robin born in it so
It doesn't do the same things as the new Attilia Robin you can't run the 11th harmonic frequencies and things like that
But you at least have the old F
101 born in the true rife machine the newer true rife machines don't have that board. So
That's why we switch to the Attilia Robin or one of the reasons so I don't know unless I opened up your machine and looked at it
If they just did a hyper drive repair then I doubt if they changed to the board
I want to think they would have charged to an awful lot of said money if they would have changed out everything on it
so
If it makes any difference, I have the F1 22 and it's already not working again. Oh my goodness
I certainly could take a look at it and we should probably talk I would need to know what is not working
on it in order to tell you whether I think I could help you or you would have to get it back to true rife
I do know that I did talk to Jake at true rife recently and he said that they're coming up with a whole new machine
Which I would think if I was talking to any other company I would be excited about it
but talking to true rife I'm not as excited about it and it makes me think that they're not going to service the F1 22's after this new machine comes on it
I don't know I'd be in maybe a little overly cynical in that case but that's what happened when they bought the company they decided they're not going to serve service the F1 17's
so
I
I don't I can't make a judge will call on what that company is going to do
But it's because of things like that that we decided to make a switch so
If you call us if you're saying you're it's already not working again
Let us know what isn't working and then I can tell you if I think I can help you and fix it or not so
Okay, the next question that our fold appointment last week you said to hold off taking fed bed is all on your cheek swab analysis
You haven't listed to take
Did the swab data give you
Change it by nodal and I just left it on there because we're going to go back on it for
I thought will we spoke
I remember this correctly that when we spoke about the fed bed is all we wanted to wait until we get your blood work back
So I want to look at your blood work before we go back on the fed bed is also stay off of it until we get that blood work back
So remember if a person's taking the bed is all we have to make sure that it's not negatively affecting their liver
And we would see that on blood work on a comprehensive
metabolic panel not a basic metabolic panel
So if you're going into the doctor to get blood work
If you have the ability to request what they're going to do
You want
CBC with differential and a comprehensive metabolic panel at minimum
So
Anything less of that is not going to give you an update and make any assessments on anything
I have no idea why they would run a basic metabolic panel on anyone
So we need to see the liver markers
So that will tell us that will show us the ALT, AST and alcohol and phosphatase, which is essential
Which can be if which fed bed is all kind of fact
so
That's what I wanted to hold off until we look at that blood work
What about Ibermectin then should I continue on that and how often
I don't see that I don't
We haven't seen anything as possible
So when you're Ibermectin is still in medication and it can still possibly
Adversity affect the liver
But we just haven't seen that
So I have a lot of people taking Ibermectin
And it's just does not tend to again
Everybody's individual and it could happen with you
But it does not tend to have the ill effects on the liver as
Spend bed is all can
But remember it's only about 50% of the people that have the
ill effects of the liver with fed bed is all but we have had almost 0%
Have ill effects on Ibermectin so I would say you could continue with Ibermectin
How often you should take Ibermectin?
I didn't test it. I can't legally test the Ibermectin with the cheek swab test
But in general how often should a person take Ibermectin?
Well again, that's the that frequency is kind of all over the board
The only thing that you can say with certainty with Ibermectin is if you take too low of a dose
If you're not at a cancer-killing dose, it's really not beneficial
So remember the dosage for Ibermectin we have it on the members site
The first page, the homepage of the member site
But the dosage for Ibermectin is you take your weight
In pounds converted to kilograms
So let's say you weigh 50 kilograms
Well then the starting dose for Ibermectin is
1.5 milligram per kilogram weight
So my starting dose for Ibermectin would be 25 milligrams per day
And then you could go up to 1 milligram per kilogram weight
And there are some people that don't think I have any current patients that are doing this right now
Some people can take 1.5 to even 2 milligrams per kilogram weight
That's a lot
But you know, a person's got stage 4 cancer and was given a month to live by their medical doctor
I mean, I would do that
But if you're not in those dire straits
Then I would stay at the starting dose
Or maybe up to 1 milligram per kilogram dose
And then how often do you take it
Now typically with venbenzo, you're pulsing it
You're going like 4 days on, 3 days off
For 3 days on, 4 days off, for 5 days on, 2 days off
For 2 weeks on, 2 weeks off
And the pulse rate, even though the original Joe Tippen's protocol for venbenzo
With 3 days on, 4 days off
There's people doing all sorts of different things
And I have patients doing all sorts of different pulses
Some people will do 3 days on venbenzo, 4 days on, Ivervectin
And then 3 days off, Ivervectin and 3 days on venbenzo
So it's all over the board
So partially, it depends on whether you are
You know what condition you're in
If your cancer is growing in a state of rapid replication, then I would hit it harder
And maybe I would just stay on it
Ivervectin is one that you can stay on
But again, I wouldn't stay on Ivervectin like long term
But it's certainly one that you don't necessarily need to pulse
Now the negative Ivervectin tends to be a little more difficult to get
Ivervectin is prescribed or to get it
So to have it on hand
So you have to factor that in as well
Question from the chat that refers back to the true right repair that was done
First it said also the repair was $325 for the hyperdrive repair
So that may indicate just a repair not a replacement
I would say yes, yes, that's just a repair not a replacement
The replacement would have probably been $1,500 or something
The unit works the bulb
But not the pro ion pro wave
Rather than send everything in for them for evaluation. I just ordered a new
ion pro wave
First actually too
If
Then since they were on sale
Thinking even if that doesn't solve the problem I'll eventually need another ion pro wave anyhow
But now I think I may be wasted my money if they're not going to support the F
122s of the future now again
I'm just speculating based upon their past actions so I don't know that
Um, if a new ion pro wave doesn't work
I'll ask you more on the next call
Which will be soon
And then the question about fed that bed is off and bed is all definitely impacted my liver
I had to quit doctor has
It be taking Ivervectin five days on two days off
Um, yeah, so we've had a lot of people that I've had to take off of fed bed is all and to pulse it
I would say 50% of the people
That we have go on fed bed is all
And they can tolerate it just fine. It does not affect their liver negatively at all
And then 50% it does
And if it does affect your liver then you either have to go off of it
Or pulse it
I mean most people have been fine just pulsing it. They may be go on for two weeks off for two weeks
Or on a month get their check liver checked it's it the the numbers have gone up
And they wait a month off of it a month to get a check to get it goes down and then they go on again
Um
Question that pertains to that any question any success with Todd cut helping with the liver with fed bed
So Todd cut is a is an aid for liver detoxification
So all of my patients that are in fed bed are doing something
Similar to Todd cut if not Todd cut for helping with that
Um, and it's just it doesn't seem it either it's going to affect your liver. It's not going to affect your liver
Uh, all the data line root, milk, this will in Todd cut and everything that you would do to help try to flush out the phase one
pace to pathway
Doesn't seem to be able to
Make a difference
Now I will also say that the dosage of fed bed is all makes a difference too
people on the the original um
dosage of fed bed is all which was the joe tip and protocol
And the pulse rate of that was three days on four days off and only taking one packet of that which was an equivalent of 222 milligrams of fed
End is all three days a week
So they're only taking 222 milligrams per day those three days
So that dose itch was lower than what
Is out there being recommended by people like dr. William backus sometimes will put people in a thousand milligrams of fed bed is all
Um, and i've her back then you know
But he's also dealing with uh making those recommendations for people who
Maybe are in more dire straits we need their cancers growing like crazy and they've been given them up to live
Again, if i was in that kind of situation i would go high dose
You know, but
When you're not in that kind of situation you do want to continue to look at those liver markers because you certainly
It doesn't seem to make much sense for a person's die of liver failure
um, but they've effectively
you know
Killed the cancer that makes no sense. So we have to
We have to try to make sense of this and be rational thinkers as we go through this
So so that we don't injure ourselves with the therapy
Um, don't don't be clouded in your thinking that you know that
And then does all and i've her back then are natural ways to kill cancer
um quote-unquote
They're alternative I would say they're um alternative to
Keyblade therapy radiation surgery
Um, but they're not natural
Uh, they're still drugs
So
Whereas you know, you do chemotherapy which is an oxidizing agent to kill cancer kills healthy cells too
And causes oxidative stress to healthy cells and can actually be a cause of cancer
But if you do
You know b-17, let's say or you're doing you know, SCAC or you're doing you know those are natural approaches
To a cancer that are gonna spare healthy cells and can actually be beneficial to healthy cells as well
So let's not confuse that
You know, doing that as a liver vector that are quote-unquote natural. They're alternative, but they're not natural
Okay, what's the difference
When one is in remission versus no evidence of disease
I will positive attitude perspective. I don't like saying my cancer
And no evidence of disease
Sounds better to me than remission if signature of blood tests MRIs
Etc. Show no cancer
I do recognize our immune systems are often kill-y cancer cells on a regular basis
Well, I agree. It's I think whatever you want to say
That helps you from an emotional standpoint
You can call it whatever you want
Be personally if somebody says how's your cancer. I typically say
I feel like I'm in full remission
Because I also don't want to be foolish and sometimes I am
About you know forgetting about my cancer than just
Going back to a bad diet which I tend to do
So I know I have to be cognizant of my weaknesses
So I keep that in the back of my mind that I need to take better care of myself
Um, and diet is the thing that I struggle with from my fleshly standpoint
so um
I
Like to kind of remind myself that even though I don't think about my cancer on a daily basis like I used to
Because I don't have the symptoms anymore and because scans did show
You know, your complete remission
Um, we also want to balance that with
You know, I've had patients come to me
You know, they first come to me. They said they were you know given
No evidence of disease
diagnosis by their oncologist a year ago and now the cancer is back with a vengeance and it spread all over their body and
And the colleges basically told them to call hospice that's happened that happens
In our office at least on a monthly basis that we get a call of somebody in that situation maybe even more frequently than that
And I think it's sad that when you to give a person
This false hope like you beat cancer. It's God don't have to think about anymore
And then they go back to a bad lifestyle that got them there
But in truth
Maybe people in that some people in that situation
Never made any lifestyle changes anyhow. They they they relied on the standards of care
Approach to get them into a state of remission, which is great
But you know if you don't change what got you where you were
Then you know, it's going to come you know, you're going to be back to where you were again. So
Whatever works with our what's your mindset is what's important if you can stay on the straight and arrow and be eating well and doing the right things
um, you know that you know, sometimes the diagnosis cancer pushed us to
Then you could just say I don't have cancer anymore
I have a lot of patients that just don't want to don't want to admit that they have cancer because they don't want to put that in their mind
They don't want to give the devil a foothold
um
And that's just fine. We all have to
stink um
And use our mind correctly what's going to help us stay as healthy as possible as well
So
What is a good protocol for addressing chemo-induced peripheral neuropathy?
I do own a rebuilder are there nutraceuticals that could help rebuild nurse
You recommend acupuncture how long does it take
Does PEMF help do products like
uh beaver help or the ISIS uh PEMF device
So the beaver and the ISIS are are PEMF devices. They're just low
Gauss PEMF devices
And then there's
devices like the pulse which are high-go Gauss PEMF devices
Any PEMF device is going to help
The rebuilder is going to be best because it's going to be
stimulating the nerves at their own frequencies
um
Derbs grow back and heal at only about a millimeter a day
Um, I don't know if there's any new data of that but that's what I learned years ago when I was in school
So it's a slow process
so um
chemo-induced
neuropathy
Is death of the death of the neurons
because of
the chemotherapy so chemotherapy is a toxic substance that can kill
um
rapidly replicating cells and
And it can damage neurons and it can stay in harbor in peripheral areas
That's why you end up with peripheral neuropathy
Because you have less blood flow, poor circulation, poor lip tradeage, peripherally
So how do you get rid of that? Well, you try to do everything you can to help move circulation
So exercise is going to be key to that
um hot cold
circulation stimulation of the nerves anyway you possibly can remember your nerves
um
The end point of a nerve or we should say the beginning point of an
a-farrot nerve
So a-farrot is you know, you prick your finger out. So that's an a-farrot communication that prick of the figure
um
stimulates
receptors on your skin surface those receptors fire up your arm
and to your brain
So that is an a-farrot pathway
So would you have neuropathy, do you have no feeling
Or you have pain or you have tingly these are a-farrot nerves that are damaged
An e-farrot nerve would be a nerve that's controlling muscle function
So that's coming from the brain down to that area
So it's the a-farrot pathways what are called the large diameter a-farrot pathways that are damaged
in peripheral neuropathy
So the more you could do to stimulate those nerves the better
I think I have a video on um
So I think I have the video I know it's on the rebuilder um
uh
add
or
the rebuilders on the store under the rebuilder
um
I think I have a video where I explained to a couple staff people
the large diameter a-farrot pathway, etc
um
but
just to
The stated again
more succinctly would be that these receptors at the skin surface are
primarily hot and cold receptors
vibration receptors
and pain receptors
So uh any way that you can stimulate those receptors
are going to stimulate growth and healing of that nerve
So nerves work on a you know you use it or lose it basis
so the more you can you can stimulate that neural pathway
the more that you're going to grow that neural pathway
So um
that's you know
how the rebuilder works it's using electrical stimulation at the frequency of the nerve
to help rebuild that pathway
but also you can
you can stimulate the other receptors
So you have it a little vibration plate you can buy a little vibration plate for your feet
um
That's and that's that's at a slant where it's supposed it's made to sit in front of a chair while you're sitting watching tv
And you put your feet on it with your socks on it with just in your
And um and it's helped but they're made to really feel comfortable on your feet
But that stimulation that vibration
helps rebuild nerve pathways
It's actually really good for your brain. It's really good for neurology
So just put in your feet out of there and stimulating that those pathways can help rebuild that
Put in your feet in hot to cold water
stimulating those pathways
Walking outside barefoot walking out of doubt a gravel driveway
Oh gosh it's painful it hurts
Well keep doing it you will build up calluses the more you can stimulate those nerves
The more you can stimulate your brain
So it's not only good for the peripheral neuropathy
It's a good brain-based therapy for your brain to keep your brain alive
So your brain is just a combination of neurons
So the more you can stimulate those neurons the better off it's going to be
And you can stimulate them through peripheral receptors
Primarily pain hot and cold vibration
Um and the better it's going to be for those neurons that if you're a pathway and your brain
So you are also helping keep your brain alive by doing this as well
So the PEMF is just using
electrical stimulation same way so the more you could do the PEMF
um the
acupuncture
Similar to
So is acupuncture good? Yeah is that can help? I would say sure
Chiropractic getting chiropractic adjustments that could help too
The more stimulation of your surface of your body the more stimulation of the muscles
The better off you're going to be then from a
Nutritional chemistry side the more you could help move the lymph
The better off it's going to be rubber lymph moves by action of the muscles
The lymph does not have a heart pushing it through
The lymph system is a vascular system that has
Heaps of valves in it every few centimeters and you need motion in order to move lymph through that tissue
To help get rid of the toxins the poisons from the chemotherapy
And then you need to detox these things so once it gets into the lymph system it goes into the vascular system
It goes through the liver and the liver has to go through phase one two three detox pathways
So remember go back to the seven phases of detox course to learn more about that
Anything you do to help support liver pathways the better off you're going to be
That's kind of a little overview of that help that helps
Next
Do you recommend the use of
dip
low semide
While using iverbectin and fed mendazole
I don't know exactly what you're asking there. So
Uh
The close-amide is
Oh, that's another
tapeworm drug. Okay. So
Now I know what the question is. So
There is a thought process out there
that um
The reason why iverbectin and fed mendazole and or mendazole work is because
For cancer is that
That can because cancer is parasite of course. That's why it works
So that you take an anti-paracidic medication
And um, it's gonna kill the cancer
um, I totally disagree with that line of thinking
Um, I don't think that's why iverbectin and fed mendazole work. The close-amide is another drug that works on tapeworms
Where iverbectin and fed mendazole do not work on tapeworms. They work on roundworms
um and
somewhat on liver flukes
um, but the close-amide is gonna work on tapeworms
So that's the theory as well to the close-amide also because then we're gonna hit all the parasites
totally
Don't agree with that
And the reason is is that
Studies on iverbectin and fed mendazole and why it tends to work with cancer
List multiple things, but it's not because of its anti-paracidic properties
The main reason why i believe that those work with cancer is they upregulate the p53
genetic pathway
So remember your genetics the p53 pathway is a tumor suppressor pathway
So remember you have all these different tumor suppressor genes that turn on
If you have a cell that goes in rapid replication
So you've heard of the bronca genes all the bronca genes are tumor suppressor genes
particularly in the breast and the
ovaries
people with bronca gene defects
if a cell goes into rapid replication
the defects prevent the bronca tumor suppressor system from destroying that cell
And then the cell can continue to replicate
thereby finally give you a diagnosis of cancer
Now there are other
Traverse suppressor genes
The p53 is actually the most prominent tumor suppressor gene
If one has defects in their p53 system
They're gonna have a more difficult time
destroying cancer for the inside out with called the intrinsic
A poptotic pathway
So the intrinsic inside the cell a poptotic death cell death pathway
Is gonna be less apt to kill a growing cancer if a person has defects other p53 genes. That's why we test for those
However
If we upregulate the p53 system whether you have defects or not
You're gonna have a better chance of that turning on and destroying the cancer
So there's lots of things that upregulate the p53
Tumoric upregulates the p53 system
Green T extract EGCG can upregulate the p53 system
Ivermectad infendizol also upregulate the p53 pathway
So remember we can upregulate tumor suppressor pathways
Increase the function of them
Then if we could increase the function of them
They have a better chance of destroying the cancer for the inside out via the intrinsic a poptotic pathway
So I do not believe that it's that it's the anti-paracidic properties of
Ivermectad infendizol that destroy cancer
It's the genetic
It's effect of the genetic p53 pathway that doesn't
Now there's other studies that show other pathways metabolic pathways that these are also work on
And helping destroy cancer
But there's not really data saying it has anything to do with parasites
I try to take clear digest each meal
But I forget
Sometimes I'll remember an hour after I ate
Is it helpful to take it then how late is too late? I don't want to add HCl to an empty stomach
Well the danger of adding HCl to an empty stomach is
If you have a healthy empty stomach, there's really not much of a danger
But if you have an ulcer in an empty stomach it's going to irritate that ulcer. It's going to give you a really bad stomach ache
But if it's it's not doing its purpose if you're adding HCl and digestive enzymes
To an empty stomach where your food is you know, there's nothing in there to digest
So how long does it take for food to go from your stomach into the small intestine?
Well the length of the length of time it takes to go
From your stomach to the toilet is called your intestinal transit time and everybody is a little bit different
But you want to have an intestinal total intestinal transit time of less than 24 hours really
Meaning if you ate corn on the cob today, you want to see it in the toilet tomorrow
The partially digested parts because it's hard to digest all that
So if you don't see it in your stool for three days your intestinal transit time is way too long
And you're probably reabsorbing a lot of toxins. That's not good
You're definitely a need of a product like clear digest if that's the case
Because clear digest will help you break down foods remember
If you're going to get nutrition from your food you need to digest it first
So the process of digested starts with your mouth and in you chewing
And in your salabaric glands release talent
And you
Have amylase secreted and that will start to break down the carbohydrates
And then you chew up your food really good and you swallow it in the stomach you have HCl
To help break down proteins and partially carbohydrates
To prepare for it to go into the first part of the swallow test in which
you have bile
From the liver which helps break down fats and the pancreas
Gives all the digestive enzymes amylase and proteases to help break down proteins and fats as well
So
That's
If you don't break your food down well
All sorts of bad things can happen. You're not going to absorb nutrients well from it
If you're going to end up with gut problems and you're going to have more irritation
You're not breaking down your proteins into amino acids. You're going to end up with food allergies
You're eight if you don't have proper HCl you're not going to
Secrete intrinsic factor which is necessary for you to absorb B12
and you're
going to end up with
possible parasites because proper HCl and your stomach is your first defense against pathogens
Not just parasites but bacteria and viruses
You're touching your food
The air is touching your food even if you're living it at a septic environment. You're still swallowing pathogens
So your first defense against pathogenic infection
That's food board is a proper pH of your stomach
being very acidic and and that's
That is produced only by HCl
So then it's a vicious cycle because you know you have irritation of the stomach because because of this and then you produce less HCl
This is vicious cycle so taking a product my cure clear digest can help you
Acidify your stomach and it helps you break down
Seven of the foods with the digestive enzymes and clear digest
I like that because it also adds bile to help you with fat digestion
and it takes stress off your
Paygress
But that wasn't even the question would you just shut up and get to the answer here?
How late is too late? Well, I think if it's an hour afterwards you're too late. Okay, just wait till you eat next time
Parsley it depends on what you ate so if you ate a big meal and it's just sitting there
You know what it's like after you've been turkey dinner things give me dinner and boy you just feel stuffed
For an hour and hour might not be too late. So
You know that food the larger meal takes longer to get through so an hour might not be too late
But if it's just a regular small meal and hour might be too late
Um, but again, there's not a harm in taking it unless you have you know a very irritated stomach wall or an ulcer
Then you're gonna feel it you're gonna go oh god, I'm not gonna do that again
But it's not gonna damage it anymore. It's just a matter of
Not
Be there to do its job
But even that digestive enzymes it clear digest will go through your into your small intestine quickly
Will help help break down foods from there
The days I am fasting should I take supplements some have to be taken with food
Uh, so remember fasting with cancer
Typically you don't want to fast more than 24 hours, but
Let's say you're doing a fast where you're doing a time restricted eating you're not eating to
Six o'clock or something
So should I take my supplements in the morning? Well, there's two lines of thinking there
So the purpose of doing fasting is
I'm trying to lose weight. I don't want any caloric intake because I'm trying to lose weight
Then that that line of thinking that you don't take your supplements when you're fasting
I'm not trying to fast to lose weight. I'm just trying to fast to stimulate autophagy
Um, and to be healthy
Well, then I would take my supplements
Um, the ones you have to take with food then you will take them you'll have to wait
um, so but otherwise I would take my if I was dealing what I was dealing with
My cancer when I was in bad shape
I was doing a lot of time restricted eating and I was doing a lot of fasting
But I was still taking all my cancer killings supplements
So
I would I would still stay on that
looking at
The vdr genes of my genetics report. I will a little bit confused
There are 11 primary genes listed the blue red arrows and metrics are confusing me
So the blue and red arrows that are up and down arrows are suggested that the data
uh
Suggest defects either up regulate that gene or down regulate that gene
So that's what that means
Um, no
No, if doesn't have an arrow at all, it's typically thought that it's that gene is down regulated
However, if it's um if it's got a down arrow then there's a ton of data that says it definitely
regulates that gene
Beat it
if I have a
The vdr gene the vdr gene are the vitamin D receptor gene so this person's talking about vitamin D
absorption
So if um, if the arrow is down
I mean, if I have a defector that g it's going to be strongly down regulated
If it's up then it's that it doesn't mean strongly it just means that
The research is opposite of what is typically normally thought
Now finish this question for example the first gene that F-O-K-L gene the vdr
F-O-K-L gene has a blue upward arrow
next to it
a one variant and a metric of g-A
46.8 that means you have a singly little defect of the vdr F-O-K-L gene
And it is a gene that typically up regulates absorption
And then percentage 46.8 is that
46.8% of the people also have that identical variant maybe have a one variant
So that really means nothing, okay? So it means that that's really
That's really a mute point
So I wouldn't say there's anything wrong with your vdr genes based upon that
The next eight all have downward pointed arrows
Bad, right? It only means it's bad if you have defects
So it means that it's down the defects of those genes
strongly downregulate that the vitamin D receptor
So if the person has ones or twos out there or a lot of ones or several twos on some of those eight genes
Then they're going to have a more difficult time eating their vitamin D levels up
But you said you have no variants and all metrics are 90% or higher
So those are not common genes to have defects on because 99% of the people have no defects on those genes
The last two one of which is the tacky gene the TAQI gene
But one that you mentioned specifically a couple weeks ago have no arrows
One variant and the metrics are close to 47%
So if you only have a single little defect half the people in the country have that same defect
And then that means that that's not a major issue
And now the tacky gene doesn't have an arrow because
There's a whole data
Set about the tacky gene that that is a
A big player in vitamin D receptor issues
So does that mean that you're going to have major issues with vitamin D?
No, it doesn't again when you look at your genes
You have a blank which means you don't have any defect on the gene you have a one maybe you have a single little defect on the gene
Or you have a two you have a double little defect on the gene
Really what you're really looking for is the are the twos
And most your genes
That because most your genes when you have a defect it's going to down regulate that gene pathway
So when you're really looking at the twos or let's say out of these
These 11 genes in the BDR genes
If you had
ones and twos on all of them and they were very uncommon gene so
They it's for person to have defect so
Instead of it say 46% it was only 6%
Only 6% of the population have that same defect you do
And you have other gene defects in that same family of genes
Then you're probably going to have more of a problem with that gene
So that's how I assess your genes
You know that what's the greater chance you have a problem
And remember what you're looking at genetics just because you had let's say you have all twos
It doesn't mean it's not going to work
It just means you have a chance of it not working
You know greater chance of it not working than somebody who doesn't have those defects
So you recommended taking smaller doses more frequently
And my functional doctor wants me to switch to liposomal
um
D and above that the sentence was so my genetics
Are my genetics a problem with absorbing D do you think
I have had higher labyrinths in the last few doses
So I don't think your genetics are really an issue with you absorbing D
So remember like absorbing the nutrient
When we have the vitamin D receptor genes to look at what's vitamin D
There's other factors too
How damaged is my epithelial wall
You know, do I have leaky gut issues?
Do I have other issues
You know if I have a concurrent with vitamin D
If I have a concurrent autoimmune issue
That's going to be goblet up by vitamin D giving me low vitamin D levels
So if I have issues with fat
Absorption in general because I had my gall bladder removed
Or I have a very slungish gall bladder
So I'm going to have it more difficult time absorbing fat soluble nutrition
So there's other factors not just genetics
So you want to look at other factors
Will taking liposomal vitamin D be better?
Maybe
So only when when if I don't is to try it
And see if that raises your levels
Typically taking liposomal vitamins
Is better the only thing that I would say about vitamin D
Vitamin D is already a fat soluble vitamin
I don't know that rapid in a fat
That's what liposomal nutrition is
It's the nutrient that's basically wrapped in a fat
So that you have a better chance of absorbing it
I don't know how the better
I haven't seen the studies that better absorb
liposomal D or not
Doing liposomal glutathione or the liposomal C
Or the other liposomals
And nutrients that are tend to be more difficult to absorb
Makes more sense
But we just don't know
It's just something you certainly can try
And then look at your levels and see if it makes a difference
Now I have much more other questions on the chat
Are there ways to lower ones blood pressure naturally?
I can't take blood thinning meds or supplements
I have a pacemaker and the heart rate is usually in good range
So lowering ones blood pressure
Yes, there's a lot of different things that you could take
For lowering your blood pressure
Now the issue is
Remember if you also have cancer
Then some of those things you have to at least take an account
So one of the better things to
There's a lot of different herbs that could lower blood pressure
Like Hawthorne and Valerian root and different things like that
We have nutrition out there that one supplements
Probably our best cellion supplement from restorative formulas is
HTN complexes HTN something
You just search HTN on our store
They have an extra strength and a regular strength
That has got some of those herbs in it
But one of the quickest ways to lower ones blood pressure is using nitric oxide supplements
So nitric oxide could help bind to the smooth muscle receptors
In the smooth muscles that lie right underneath
The endothelial cells, the light of the vessels
And it's those smooth muscles that are in a state of contraction
With somebody who has high blood pressure
So the definition of high blood pressure is
contraction of the smooth muscles that lie in the endothelial cells
Because that makes the lubit of the vessel smaller
And the pressure going through there is faster
So if I had a great big pipe and I only have so much water going through it
The pressure is going to be real slow
But if I shrink my pipe to a half inch pipe diameter
The water is going to be racing through there
That's what blood pressure is
So problem with nitric oxide supplements
So if the person came to me, they didn't have
Cancer and they had high blood pressure
We go on a nitric oxide supplement
That's, I put them on herbal supplements too
But that's the fastest way to deal with that
Plus you want to deal with H. Pylori
Because that's probably the most common reason why
The smooth muscles are in contraction of the first place
But nitric oxide will open up those vessels
But nitric oxide also increases the vascular endothelial growth factor
And you don't want that for cancer
So I would do if I had a diagnosis of cancer
And I wasn't in remission
And I had high blood pressure
I would go on the herbal route first
They are just off label
Oh yes, off label
I'll just talk about that other
We'll talk about FitBend's own stuff
My AST and ALT have improved since going off FitBend
Alpha alkaline phosphatase is still high
I've started having acid reflux
Or acid indigestion
Could they be related or are they separate
Is acid reflex related to
Elevated alkaline phosphatase
No, I don't think so
So the way you would differential diagnose
Whether by elevated ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase is coming from
You know, what is that coming from
So you kind of go through this process of
Well, if the ALT and AST are going to be elevated
If there's irritation to the liver
alkaline phosphatase can be also elevated
But with the person with a diagnosis of cancer
alkaline phosphatase can also be elevated
If they have metastasis
So alkaline phosphatase is elevated
If there's irritation to the liver
Or there's there's tissue damage
Some or else
Most cowardly tissue damage to the bone
So if I have metastasis to the bone
By alkaline phosphatase is going to go up
Many times it will follow
We follow by calcium B and elevated as well
Because the irritation, the destruction of the
Bone is going to elevate calcium levels
So that's how you'd kind of walk through that
Differential diagnosis
I have AST elevated ALT elevated alkaline phosphatase
Well, let's say calcium is normal
Then I go off a fed bed
My AST and ALT go down
But my alkaline phosphatase stays up
I'd want to say okay, where's my calcium at
Well, I calcium is still higher than normal
Well, do I don't have no metastasis somewhere
I would want to be looking for that
Because the wall alkaline phosphatase can go up
With a drug irritation like fed bed is all
If it stays elevated and the other to go down
I'd go, huh
Do I have no metastasis?
Is there growth and destruction somewhere else
That's what I don't want to look at
Could that be related to a heavy acid reflux
Or acid in digestion
I would say no
Probably not
You could say well
One of the first days metastasis to the stomach
Well the test is the stomach is quite rare
So I wouldn't even think that
Acid reflux
And
Indigestion are going to be
Obviously quite common
It's probably most common symptom
There is
Even non-cancer patients
And it's always tied to
And HCL deficiency
So go back to my blog
And look at the hypochloridria blog posts
Think about
Starting with the apple cider vinegar
Or something like that to call the stomach
Maybe get it on GI soothes
To help heal the stomach
That's one of the things I would first think about
So
That's kind of my thoughts on that
Next question
My absolute lymphocytes is a different person
Was 1500
Then 1368
In 2024
In September it was 1053
Is that mean my immune system is going down
My white blood cell count is 5.4
The last test the other numbers are good
No it doesn't
And me that you're if you're
If you're
Immune system is
Dropping, you know to say immune system
There's many components of the immune system
Not just your white blood cells
But when you're concerned about a suppressed immune system
You're going to see a decrease in white blood cell count
Now there can be multiple reasons for that long-term cancer
Can be one of them
Long-term viral infection can be another one
There can be you know
There's lots of different reasons
Immune
Deficiency diseases can factor into that too
But if your white blood cell count is 5.4
That's not an issue
And you're you're lymphocyte
And your neutrophil your differential count is going to vary
Depending on what's going on at that that specific time
So again, lymphocytes are going to be elevated
If the person has an infection
That's
More apt to be viral
Neutrophils are going to be elevated
The person has an infection that's more apt to be bacterial
But your absolute counts are going to vary
From time to time
And you know, we all have different things that we're fighting off
At different times that we don't have full off infections
So no
Next question
I've had success with acupuncture
Improving my chemo induced neuropathy
Well, that's good for the other person that has that question
It impacted my motor nerves
More than my sensory nerves
And I got to the point where I was afraid to walk to the mailbox
I have now
Walk 8 to 10,000 steps a day
That was after my 8, 7 to 8 acupuncture sessions
Well, that's a huge applause for that
One of the issues that you have with peripheral neuropathy
Is that you can't feel the bottom of your feet
Where your sensory nerves die
So you're much more apt to trip and fall
And damage yourself
And you can't tell where you feel where you are in space
The trip going upstairs and things like that
So it's important to
Do everything you can to stimulate
Those things
So that's a good testability for acupuncture
Thank you Deborah
Dr. C, how about grounding mats for neuropathy?
Foot massage
So grounding mats for neuropathy
Yeah, I mean, anything's worth trying
Foot massage
Yes, any kind of stimulation is going to be great
Do you sell a vibration mat?
We don't sell a vibration mat
The vibration plate
If you just look it up real quick
We used to have it on my brain-based therapy
I used to do a lot of brain-based therapy
And on one of my brain-based therapy charts
I had one
I was listed from Amazon
But that was a long time ago
So I just searched on Amazon vibration plate
And there's a ton of them
There's some that you stand on and vibrate
There have been for exercising
There are some that are tilted
That you can just step
You put your feet on
They're all like a hundred bucks
You know, they're pretty cheap
So I would just go on Amazon
And get them
It's not the it's not the frequency of vibration
That is important
For stimulating those neurons
You just need to stimulate the vibration
Receptors
So that's the whole key
Why is it that chemo-adjuster apathy
Got way worse months after I stopped
Do I still have chemo-adjuster apathy
Yeah
Yes, you do
So we're not exposed to toxins
I mean, here, I've done the toxic detect test on you
You're on that toxic detect test
And you're like
Holy cow, look at all these toxins that have my body
You weren't exposed to those recently
They're cumulative effect on you
And again, your level of toxicity is equal to
The amount of toxic exposure you've had
Over your entire lifetime
Might as your ability to get rid of that toxic exposure
So the degree that you don't get rid of things
It settles in your tissues
And it's
When it circulates throughout your bloodstream
Because they put it in
Irreveasantly
It's going to settle in your tissues
In an area that is
You know most peripheral
So
Yeah, it does it stays in you
So what a key later like zeolite or something like that be beneficial
Yes, it can be
So using
A key later zeolite is a key later
Can be beneficial to pull it out
Remember go back to my seven phases of detox
You've got to make sure that you're
You got you dealt with phase six five four three two one
Before you go to zero, which is key lady
Next question, I sleep on a grow bean sheet
I do not do foot massage
Vibration machine was too strong for me
I might have had more success with a gentle one
What's good news?
Next question, could you review the lymphatic issues related to chemotherapy
I recently developed a swollen right ankle very weird as I have never had swelling
And now way less than a hundred pounds
So you're so if you have a swollen right ankle
What's that cause from
Well
There's some
There's some blockage
And so it's only on the right side
Right so why so there's some blockage
In that the lymph systems ability to remove that fluid
The truth is you're producing fluid
Extra
Cellularly
Constantly so
Every cell of your body is is metabolically active
Every cell of your body is producing waste
That waste is extruded outside the cell membrane into what's called the extracellular space
The extracellular space is just space between cells
And then you have open ended capillaries
Kind of like storm sewers that drain that extracellular space
And those open ended capillaries are called lymph vessels
Now the lymph vessels then pick up that waste that waste flows into there. Well how
By action of the muscle by contraction of the surrounding muscles
So the only way
Waste
Whether it's waste
Toxic waste or whether it's waste that's just
um
From autophagy of cell death or cell breakdown or cell
Metabolic processes that waste goes into the extracellular space and then it has to flow into the lymph system
To get out of the body
That's the only way it gets out of the body
So it's got to flow into that storm sewer and it does so by contraction of muscles
So motion is so important
So if you're not contracting your muscles
Even the simple is just moving your feet around moving your toes
So that's the other thing is just writing the alphabet with your feet or with your toes with your ankles
Getting it up and doing some leg raisers action of muscle contraction
Moves it into the blood into the lymph vessels and remember their lymph vessels
Every several centimeters. There's a
Valve a one-way valve so we can only go one way of it
I can't go back and it just keeps pushing through pushing through pushing through until it gets to a vessel to it gets to a
Vessel in your body that's gonna then that's part of the vascular system
Um, and that's the Venus system. So it doesn't go back into the artery goes back into the V the Venus system
It's gonna be carried then back to the liver where it's gonna
We pulled out of the liver. So if you have blockage in that lymph
Pathway, that's what's gonna give you that that swelling like that
Now if you're at swelling on both ankles then you'd start thinking
Possibly
Issues with sodium you know potassium balance etc
There's some other blood chemistry issues. Why maybe you're just
The your the vessels are losing fluid
So you could get fluid build up in the
Extravities because your vessels become more permeable because of imbalance in blood electrolyte
Activity, but if it's on one side it kind of rules that out. It's more so
Uh, a lymphatic issue now a person can have lymphatic issues that they never do about
Because of an old injury to there. Let's say this is your okay. This is
Your right ankle. Let's say you hurt your right knee when you're at high school
You don't you remember it anymore, but you actually damaged the lymph vessel
But you haven't never even noticed any swelling in your right ankle before because you didn't go through chemo
You know, so it's um
That you think of stings like that
Um, but also think of structural things and maybe how you're sleeping. Are you pinching the lymph vessels in your
Uh, I bet you're in your thighs that you're not getting flow backwards
Um, our it is a lot of different structural things that you could that you could possibly be thinking of
You should have a patient who would cross their legs at work all the time in a certain way
And that that was why they were getting swelling in one side
So if you're just google a uh, um
Picture of your lymph system you could kind of see how that flow goes and how it goes back to the
Vascular system to get out of the body so you think of things like that and how it could be blocked
I do have blog posts on
lymph exercises
I think too that goes over it in more detail and things that you could do
There are some
Nutrients that can help lymph flow to some holeyopathy that can help lymph flow professional formulas make some things for lymph flow to
Cell core. I think makes a product for a lymph stem um
How well those work? I had a people
Really love them and then some people say it really didn't help them
Um, but if there is structural damage to a lymph vessel
This is the big problem with
The rest of cancer patients go in and they have surgery and they remove you know, primary lymph nodes and take on a bunch of
Uh, lymph vessels and now they have swelling in their arm all the time. It's very frustrating
Um, but they don't get in their in the oncologist's surgeon surgical mind
They're thinking we just got to remove everything that there's going to be cancer whether you leave the person
Disabled with for different things. So it's it is kind of a problem
So I would think of those kind of things. I don't think it's a like chemistry issue. It's on one side
It's more of a structural issue. It's on one side
Okay, I think with that we will
Say goodbye for the night. So thanks everybody for being done. We'll get. Thank you so much. Really appreciate all the knowledge
Oh, absolutely. Thank you guys for listening
All right, bye-bye. Well, bless you all. We'll be praying for everybody. Bye-bye